qu'en sera-t-il sécuritaire de regagner
l'espace public
à quel point à quel rythme et à quelles
conditions lakovic 19
encore méconnu soulève de nombreuses
questions chez les citoyens mais aussi
dans la classe politique
il ya aucune science encore qui indique
si on a attrapé la cave et 19 une fois
on est protégés de l'attraper une
deuxième fois
alors que s'amorce le déconfinement dans
certaines provinces
faut-il se fier au concept d' immunité
collective exposés certains groupes
coronavirus de manière graduelle
la numéro un de la santé publique au
canada mais on garde seul et ça ce n'est
pas un concept que l'on devrait soutenir
dit elle en l'absence de preuves
scientifiques plus solides concernant
l'immunité de groupe
oui il faut être extrêmement prudent
avec ce genre d' approche c est les
orties coordonnée une immunité et pour
combien de temps des remarques qui
semble contredire la proche prônée par
le premier ministre du québec
donc l'idée c'est d'y aller très
graduellement peau que les personnes qui
sont moins à risque mais puissent
développer des anticorps est capable de
devenir immunisés françois legault avait
déclaré qu'il ne prendrait aucune
décision sans l'aval de ses experts en
santé publique
aujourd'hui l'organisation mondiale de
la santé appelle à la prudence
faute de preuves impossible de garantir
l'immunité d'une personne guérie de la
codi 19
selon cet expert il faut encore
développer une meilleure connaissance du
coronavirus et des mécanismes
d'immunisation ça cette année ça c'est
si c'est difficile d'agir ou des
d'implémenter des dépôts l'été
gouvernementale et ça c'est qu'est-ce
que l'om a social de nous rappeler c'est
une période pleine de tiraillements pour
les leaders politiques concilier un
retour progressif à la normale et la
protection des citoyens
les experts en santé publique sentent le
besoin de faire ce rappel
l'incertitude est encore grande et plus
que jamais la prudence impose ici louis
blouin radio canada
ottawa